foreign
[Music]
minus one
this one is different from the first
teaser in many aspects this one shows
clips and scenes of what might very well
be his first entrance into the Limelight
of humanity it also shows where he is
from and where he is headed to as well
as the devastation that he has already
caused to the US and the Allied Navy
forces before the Japanese even knows
what is going to hit them in the face
this teaser also tells us when to expect
the full trailer and it will be coming
very very soon so as for now let's break
this teaser down in breathe
the very first picture we see is that of
a battleship in critical condition
probably damaged Beyond repair and this
was taken from probably a U.S
reconnaissance World War II airplane as
the war has already ended at that time
with a surrendered treaty signed surely
after the atomic bombings this
Battleship was definitely not struck by
any human-made weapons as the U.S Navy
Reigns Supreme in the Pacific during
that time so the perpetrator is teased
in the very next scene when the camera
pants down underwater beneath the tides
therefore implying that the cause of the
destruction was from something that came
from under the waves
we then see a scene of a sonar from one
of the U.S ships detecting a large
object underwater the equipment used
during that time in history was newly
developed and crude so to say
nevertheless it shows a huge bogey
gradually making its way towards the
ship or submarine this means that
Godzilla would be very sensitive to
sonar sounds see the way sonar works is
the sound of a particular frequency is
created and set in a desired Direction
it would then bounce off objects along
the way and return to its origin point
where receiver a receiver device would
then recapture it and show it in the
screen yeah that's just basic sonar for
dummy's explanation anyway here Godzilla
would be sensitive to such sounds and
will be attracted towards the point of
origin the next scenes show what
probably is the root of Godzilla's path
in the Pacific Ocean which means the U.S
military had been aware of this
existence as an aquatic creature for
quite a while at least way before the
Japanese did the next scene shows an
eerie boy in the middle of the sea boy
that's how you pronounce it I don't know
so these are floating objects anchored
in a definite location to guide A Worn
Mariners or to mock positions of
submerged objects anyway after that we
see a sort of a blueprint where they
assess the position and speed of an
object relative to a ship and the
fascinating thing about this is that the
speed keeps on increasing from 32 knots
to around 40 knots before being cut off
is this the speed of Godzilla maybe so
then we see a damaged ship and it was
stated officially as being caused by a
torpedo the damage a Mach 18 1 torpedo
with the engine room being flooded and
this resulted in no survivors but wait a
second there the diagram of the vessel
is actually of a youth class submarine
that was in operation with the U.S
military during World War II and again
at that time there was no other country
that had the ability to attack the US in
the sea so this is definitely the work
of Godzilla but as we can see in the
upcoming scenes the wreckages of ships
are being covered up by the military as
unknown or caused by accidents this then
Fades into a map that shows Words gazan
reto which are volcanic islands south of
the main Japanese islands close to Iwo
Jima the site of a huge Pacific battle
during World War II and these islands
might be the place of origin for the
G-Man
they also show ogasawara which indeed
confirms the location of the first
sightings and encounters with Godzilla
it seems that the US military is
tracking and researching this aquatic
creature with many of their encounters
ending in disasters as there are many
ships and vessels that are marked as
either sang or dead in the water
but what really strikes me is the map
there is a sudden change of Godzilla's
path from going westwards to a North
stride Direction directly towards the
Honshu main islands of Japan and
straight enroutes towards Tokyo with
Godzilla out speeding the U.S trackers
and a map showing a rapidly increasing
area of probability on where Godzilla
will make landfall
this ends with a warning letter
addressed to the Prime Minister of Japan
from Douglas MacArthur which at that
time on the 10th of February 1947 he was
the commander of fikom or the Far East
command and this was a unified combatant
command of the United States Department
of Defense active from 1947 until 1957
fortunately organized to undertake the
occupation of Japan and Korea the letter
says that as per the intelligence agency
with coordinated efforts with the Allied
Forces and they confirm a presence of a
massive aquatic organism heading at high
speed towards the Japanese archipelago
from the south this would mean that the
U.S had failed in containing or even
catching up to Godzilla in the Open Seas
with ads you would remember
there was an area of probability on
where Godzilla would make landfall and
yeah this ends with a photo of the Big G
at least the spiky dorsal plates
Breaking the Waves taken by a periscope
camera from probably another u-class
submarine
and yeah finally the trailer will be
released this Monday the 4th of
September
so that's all we have to say about this
teaser of Godzilla minus one stay tuned
for Monday anyway I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam